[Musique]
un bon soir mardi 17 novembre bienvenue
dans le journal de la rédaction de tv
60,18 voici les titres de l'actualité
locale avec la fermeture des commerces
mon essentiel depuis le début du
confinement des solutions s'imposent
pour poursuivre tout de même un minimum
d'activités saint quentin en yvelines va
lancer chopine sky un marché virtuel
dédié aux produits vendus dans les 12
communes de l'agglomération pour contrer
l'épidémie de kovy 19 des centres de
dépistage ouvre dans ou à proximité des
gares ils sont déployés par l'île de
france en partenariat avec les
collectivités locales et dans les
yvelines
huit garçons concernés dont celle de
saint quentin en yvelines à montigny le
bretonneux
et puis vous le savez la pratique du
sport est limité en ce moment crise
sanitaire oblige mais des dérogations
existent pour les athlètes de haut
niveau et les entraînements restent
autorisés pour une centaine de sportifs
dans le département qui prépare deux
prochaines compétitions
la décision était attendue hier elle a
été finalement proclamé ce matin
l'élection municipale est invalidée au
chesnay rocancourt par le tribunal
administratif de versailles
rappelez vous le 15 mars dernier richard
de pierre l'avait emporté sur le maire
sortant philippe brillault avec
seulement 76 voix d'écart ce dernier
avait alors déposé un recours pour faire
annuler le scrutin avec l'argument de
l'abstention due à la crise sanitaire et
d'un sondage à charge dont le résultat a
été révélé quelques jours avant
l'élection
finalement lors de l'audience le 3
novembre dernier le rapporteur public
avait demandé l'annulation pour d'autres
motifs l'affichage de trois panneaux
accusant philippe brillault d'être un
menteur ainsi qu'une photographie
diffusée sur facebook montrant une
partie de son patrimoine
le tribunal administratif a donc suivi
ses recommandations élections de richard
de pierre annulé au chesnay rck en cours
et les réactions à cette décision à
suivre dans un reportage que nous vous
proposerons ce soir sur tv 78 s est à
retrouver dans l'émission 7 8 politique
présentée par wilfrid richy ce mardi à
21h30 sur tv 78 avant de développer les
titres également ce déplacement
ministériel ce matin à guyancourt et
marlène schiappa ministre délégué à la
citoyenneté il
raynaud ministre délégué à l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et adrien
taquet secrétaire d'état visite la
plateforme de lutte contre les violences
sexuelles et sexistes
la plateforme à guyancourt a été créé il
ya deux ans installé au troisième étage
du commissariat 30 policiers et six
relais pour un service 7 jours sur 7 et
24 heures sur 24 il dialogue elle via
chat avec les victimes et depuis le 30
octobre et leur confinement le site
enregistré une hausse de 15 % des
signalements de des victimes
et si vous avez besoin ou si vous êtes
témoin de ces violences des dispositifs
d'alerté existent les informations dans
le lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
une autre visite dans le département
celle de barbara pompili ministre de la
transition écologique elle a visité hier
la nouvelle déchetterie de
l'agglomération versailles grand parc y
est installé dans la commune est
l'occasion de rappeler que contrairement
aux premiers confinement les
déchetteries reste ouverte en ce moment
[Musique]
certains ont l'autorisation d'ouvrir
d'autres sont fermées sur décision
administrative depuis le début du
confinement le 30 octobre pour les
commerces dits non essentiels une
organisation est donc nécessaire pour
tenter de s'adapter aux contraintes et
de faire face aux difficultés des
solutions existent on va en parler dans
ce journal
un peu plus tard regardez déjà à ce
sujet il a été tourné du côté de
voisins-le-bretonneux et aux
clayes-sous-bois avec nicolas landry et
justine brasier il est fermé depuis le
vendredi 30 octobre ce centre esthétique
de voisins-le-bretonneux ne peut plus
proposer de soins aux clients épilation
minceur anti-âge des prestations
proposées par nathalie puig
aujourd'hui elle compte sur la vente de
produits sur une boutique en ligne cette
activité représente 30% de son chiffre
d'affaires la fermeture administrative
une décision difficile à comprendre où
se situe le non essentiels quand on
dispense du bien-être auprès de la
clientèle
mais c'est surtout que nous les petits
commerçants et je parle au nom de tous
ceux de saint quentin et tous ceux qui
sont en france on a pris des mesures
sanitaires exceptionnellement stricte et
qu'on ne comprend pas la raison de ce
deux poids deux mesures puisque les
grandes enseignes sont elles ouvertes
dans le centre-ville des
clayes-sous-bois cette boutique de
décoration n'est pas un commerce qui est
essentielle
face à cette situation sa dirigeante
dominique duguet s'est adapté là la
situation est très très compliqué
puisque nous sommes sur des mois très
fort en chiffre d'affaires donc la
fermeture du magasin et est
catastrophique en fait et on a fait un
site très très rapidement en trois jours
on a mis six cent cinquante produits sur
le net on avait pas de site de vente on
a travaillé j'ai deux alternant qui
travaillent avec moi plus ma famille on
s'est tous mis à faire ce fameux site
au delà du site internet la commerçante
utilise aussi les réseaux sociaux en
faisant de la visio shopping un
fonctionnement virtuel en attendant de
pouvoir ouvrir les portes de sa boutique
justement pour accompagner les
commerçants dans cette phase difficile
notamment dans leur transition numérique
l agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines propose un nouvel outil h open
sky c'est un marché virtuel réunissant
les commerçants des douze communes de
l'agglomération
cette application sera disponible
prochainement sur l'app store et google
plaît plus de précisions dans cette
interview interview menée par nicolas
landry
il faudra s'habituer dorénavant à
l'application shop in sky le marché
virtuel de saint quentin en yvelines qui
regroupe l'ensemble des commerçants
présents sur l'agglomération dans les 12
communes de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et pour en parler
nous sommes avec didier fischer bonjour
bonjour vous êtes vice président en
charge des commerces alors qu'est ce que
c'est chopine sky shops in sky c'est une
application importante évidemment
puisque elle permet pour les clients
d'avoir dans leur poche l'ensemble des
je dirais des commerces de saint quentin
et pour les commerces et d'être en
contact effectivement d'être une
boutique en ligne en quelque sorte d
être en contact avec leurs oeufs avec
leurs clients pourquoi les douze
communes ont décidé de lancer ce
marketplace est place du marché virtuel
de saint quentin en yvelines
alors c'était une idée qui qui existait
depuis quelques mois mais dans le
contexte actuel vous pouvez comprendre
qu'on a accéléré le processus parce que
c'est une aide indispensable à l'heure
actuelle aux clients parlent beaucoup à
l'heure actuelle du prix comme en
collecte bien et cesser cela d'une
certaine façon c'est cela et c'est
mettre à disposition des commerçants une
application qui est une application
gratuite pour eux et qui va permettre en
principe de les aider dans la période
actuelle
concrètement comment ça va se dérouler
pour les téléspectateurs qui nous
regardent les saint quentinois qui nous
regardent
concrètement concrètement je dirais
d'ici le 20 je pense c'est le 20
novembre
l'application sera en ligne il suffira
pour eux de charger cette application
est ensuite et n'ont plus qu'à naviguer
sur cette application choisir les
commerces dans lesquels ils souhaitent
d'une manière où se rendent de dobbs
déjà dans un premier temps d'une manière
virtuelle et ensuite d'une manière plus
concrète
en allant retirer les produits qu'ils
ont qu'ils ont achetés quelle est votre
stratégie finalement derrière le
lancement de cette application la
stratégie et c'est une stratégie dead
à l'heure actuelle au commerce de
développer aussi à terme un peu plus le
commerce en ligne
nous le voyons aujourd'hui dans la dans
le contexte de crise c'est une nécessité
absolue alors dans le contexte de crise
a peut être destinées à des ce commerce
des sociétés qui sont fermées
administrativement
mais à terme du coup c'est aussi je
suppose développer les produits locaux
tout tous les produits qui peuvent être
produits sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
bien sûr bien sûr ça ça aussi c'est
important cela ça aussi cette vocation
là on est là avec une je dirais une
application qui peut amener en effet ce
type de développement
dernière question quel type de produit
on peut retrouver du coup tous les
produits pratiquement tous les produits
aujourd'hui les produits évidemment tous
les produits de première nécessité tout
ce qui est l'alimentaire mais pas
seulement l'alimentaire un là tous les
commerces pourront en effet je dirais
participer à cette application
merci didier fischer je vous en prie et
vice président en charge du commerce à
saint quentin en yvelines donc lancement
de l'application au shopping sky le 20
novembre prochain
et c'est la start-up yvelinoise
commercer à qui a été choisi par saint
quentin en yvelines pour développer
shopping sky les détails dans cette
interview express
[Musique]
commercer à sète une plateforme de
redynamisation des commerces de
centre-ville
nous ça fait cinq ans et je pense que ça
fait au moins quinze ans que les
commerces ont beaucoup de difficultés en
centre-ville on connait tous les raisons
les centres commerciaux internet et
ainsi de suite où le métier c'est de
refaire venir les consommateurs
physiquement dans les commerces
[Musique]
chaque ville va avoir une couleur un nom
un vrai identifiant pour créer une vraie
marque tous les commerçants de la ville
qui vont pouvoir y ait adhéré parce que
nous notre client c'est la mairie et la
mairie va mettre à disposition de ses
commerçants tout système c'était de la
fidélité les bons plans le couponing
l'annuaire le click and collect alors le
consommateur lui avoir une application
qui voir le nom de sa ville on l'a bien
compris donc il va y adhérer très
facilement
et là il va retrouver déjà tous ces
commerces on va revoir la diversifier la
diversification qui a dans sa ville et
il va surtout pouvoir avoir de la
fidélité arrive avoir consommé dans
chaque commerce de sa ville gagnez des
points et avoir des avantages dans ces
commerces des avantages et de vraies
réductions financières sur ses prochains
achats on est en contact avec certains
des yvelines depuis assez longtemps mais
locaux vides à accélérer les choses
évidemment
nous ce qui nous intéressait dans saint
quentin en yvelines c'est que ces douze
communes
donc c'est vraiment la preuve que l'on
peut en plus de travailler sur une vie
de travail et sur un ensemble de vivre
le village
et demain mercredi ne manquait pas un
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés ce sera
justement consacrée à la thématique de
la transition numérique pour les
commerces locaux
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines accueille
depuis hier un centre de dépistage au
kovy 19 c'est à l'initiative de la
région ile de france qui a déployé
structure dans 50 gares franciliennes à
8 sont concernés dans les yvelines
patrick jacques de dixmude et justine
brasey 300 c'est le nombre de tests
antigénique qui devrait être réalisée
par jour au nouveau centre dépistage
covit 19 une structure stratégiquement
placés au niveau de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines
les gars il ya souvent des parkings à
côté il ya souvent une bonne desserte de
bus et c'est aussi parce qu'il reste
encore 50 % des franciliens qui se
déplace le matin dans les transports en
commun la structure d'accueil et de
tester désormais à disposition des
habitants du lundi au vendredi de 13h à
19h un centre met sur pied en une
semaine
ici on avait l'opportunité d'avoir un
local
mes rations 6 lequel pouvait servir face
en accueillir au mieux les gens que dans
un barnum
dans la période où nous sommes et un
nouveau pas pour contenir la propagation
du virus selon l'agglomération espérait
relancer au plus vite l'activité
économique quand vous travaillez
c'est vrai que vous n'êtes pas dans la
même situation quand vous quand vous
quand vous avez peur quand quand même
dans quelqu'un peut le transmettre la
lave ou diminuer les acteurs de
transmission puisque quand vous le savez
vous restez chez vous par les sens voilà
vous êtes pris en charge par un médecin
s'il ya une forte charge virale 6 mai
mais a priori c'est aussi de permettre
d'organiser le retour de l'activité
économique normale dans les yvelines et
8 gare accueille déjà ou accueilleront
prochainement un centre de dépistage
antigénique au total en ile-de-france 50
grandes gares franciliennes sont
concernés le texte doit être adopté dans
les prochains jours à l'assemblée
nationale la loi de programmation de la
recherche continue de susciter des
oppositions une manifestation se
dérouler ce mardi au départ de la
sorbonne à paris et dans le cortège est
la faculté de droit de sciences
politiques de l'université versailles
saint quentin parmi les craintes
exposées le processus de recrutement des
professeurs qui pourraient être
modifiées écouter le doyen de la faculté
de la faculté interrogé par lots nord
sinoquet et michael et demi d'euros
[Musique]
cette loi de programmation pluriannuelle
pour la recherche a été amendée au début
du mois de novembre de façon assez
inattendue en modifiant les conditions
d'accès des enseignants chercheurs
maîtres de conférences et professeurs
des universités aux carrières de
d'enseignant chercheur au sein des
universités
l'idée étant donc à terme de permettre
une plus grande autonomie aux
universités pour recruter directement
les enseignants chercheurs et c'est
précisément à ce propos que je parte à
l'est de cohésion territoriale pour la
qualité d'enseignement supérieur et de
la recherche c'est que selon les
universités on pourrait trouver en
fonction de contraintes et d'un risque
de localisme au fond des enseignants
chercheurs qui seraient recrutés sur des
critères qui ne seraient pas
suffisamment exigeants au fond la
mobilisation est très forte elle vient
de toutes les universités avec des
modalités très variable ce sont des
courriers adressés aux députés aux
sénateurs au président la république au
premier ministre et évidemment à la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche de la mobilisation se
joue au sein de chaque établissement par
des motions proposées au conseil de
faculté ou du fr part également des
opérations de chaise vide au fond dans
le no1 instance et ou par des mouvements
locaux qualifiés notamment de mouvements
écran noir c'est à dire le choix que
certains collègues de ne pas dispenser
leurs cours là pour l'instant à distance
et puis s'ajoute à cela la manifestation
qui était organisée cet après midi à 15h
à la sorbonne
ce que nous attendons c'est de réouvrir
le débat de supprimer cet amendement est
d'ouvrir un dialogue constructif avec en
l'occurrence et sa chance derrière les
universitaires qui ont ont aussi une
force de proposition et de fonder une
évolution éventuelle du système sur à
une concertation avec les intéressés
l'actualité c'est aussi ces derniers
chiffres de la précarité dans les
yvelines 12 mille ménages du département
étaient accueillis en 2019 par le
secours catholique et un constat la
situation des personnes les plus pauvres
s'aggrave davantage les explications de
mélanie poker une précarité qui
s'installe dans le département et des
signaux plutôt inquiétants comme la
présence plus importante d'enfants dans
les familles c'est l'un des principaux
indicateurs ont relevé par les bénévoles
du secours catholique des yvelines
les familles avec au fond c 49 % des
ménages rencontrés pour cette année 2010
ça c'est quelque chose qui est nouveau
sur les sur les cinq dernières années où
globalement la politique familiale quand
même permettait par la présence des
enfants d'avoir des compléments de
revenus pour les ménages
aujourd'hui ces aspects là sont plus du
tout suffisant et quand on a un quart
des ménages qu'on reçoit qui sont des
femmes avec enfants des femmes et des
mères isolées on va dire ça veut dire
pour nous les yvelines
on parle de 3000 tonnes sur ces cinq
dernières années le secours catholique d
évident note aussi une dégradation
autour du logement aujourd'hui et les
bénéficiaires ont pour la plus grande
majorité un logement précaire
il n'y a pas assez de construction de
logement social on reste coincé dans du
logement d'urgence ou du logement
temporaire de l'hébergement temporaire
c'est pas de logement du coup on reste
dans une situation précaire qui ne
permet pas de se projeter à long terme
autre donnée nouvelle pour l'année 2019
la proportion d'étrangers parmi elles
les personnes accueillies une proportion
stable pour la france mais qui devient
majoritaire pour la région francilienne
et les
line 69 % des ménages rencontrés sont de
nationalité étrangère
s'ils viennent chez nous c'est qu'il ya
une dégradation de leur niveau
économique
un de leur situation et notamment pas le
droit à l'emploi
pas de droit au travail une
précarisation finalement qui se renforce
et du coup forcément ils viennent ils
viennent de rentrer à noter que ce sont
les chiffres pour l'année 2019 avec la
crise sanitaire que connaît la france
depuis le mois de mars dernier
certaines associations tirent la
sonnette d'alarmé en millions de
français seraient passés sous le seuil
de pauvreté dans le courant de cette
année 2020 il rejoindrait les 9,3
millions de français déjà recensés dans
les yvelines secours catholique a
notamment était sollicité par des
étudiants et des retraités
et c'est un public plutôt nouveau
justement à propos de la hausse de la
précarité le cris des larmes de sang
cinq maires présidents d'agglomérations
et représentants d'associations au
président de la république c'est une
lettre ouverte transmise samedi à
emmanuel macron pour je cite l'égalité
républicaine dans les quartiers
prioritaires elle nommée appel du 14
novembre
parmi les signataires une dizaine d'élus
des yvelines joséphine coleman ce berger
maire de plaisir catherine arnould de
chanteloup-les-vignes nicolas dainville
pour la verrière ou encore sonia breux
édile de saint cyr l'école dans ce
courrier les élus demandent des actes au
chef de l'état trois ans après le
discours de tourcoing où il promettait
un plan de mobilisation nationale pour
les quartiers populaires l ambition se
fait encore attendre dix les signataires
ces derniers dénoncent en pleine crise
sanitaire une non assistance aux
territoires en danger et regrette un que
les villes et les quartiers prioritaires
n'ai pas été assez pris en compte par le
plan de relance présenté par le
gouvernement
tout autre chose à présent avec ce
concept insolite qui s'est installée en
bord de seine c'est à sartrouville un
fou de conteneurs a été inauguré début
novembre les détails avec l honneur
sinoquet une ferme un conteneur maritime
deux choses qui ne devait pas se
rencontrer et pourtant c'est le pari fou
de la société indépendante living buzz
elle vient d'inaugurer son fou de
conteneurs complètement autonome des
fruits et légumes doivent petit poucet
c'est à sartrouville en bord de seine
que ce drôle de concept a pris place
alors c'est très simple dans ce
container il ya comme des jardins
m avec de la terre ce qu'on appelle de
la terre hors sol donc de la terre
normal mélangé à du compost
les plantes sont ont leurs racines qui
prennent pied danser jardinières elles
sont arrosés par de l'eau de pluie que
nous récupérons stockons filtrons est
éclairé par des led qui elle ne s'appuie
que sur de la lumière produite par des
panneaux solaires photovoltaïques
implantés en toiture du feu de container
se fout de contes narrés pour le moment
en phase d'expérimentation et ce pendant
un an soit 4 saisons ce qui permettra de
tester le système
quelles que soient les conditions météo
l'objectif c'est de démontrer qu'il est
bien possible de créer un nouveau
système de production agricole
utilisable pour tous ceux qui vivent en
autonomie en autonomie ce sont les
réfugiés dans les camps de réfugiés qui
n'ont aujourd'hui aucune possibilité de
subvenir à leurs besoins alimentaires
dans des conditions normales ce sont ce
les scientifiques qui vivent base vie
autonome le qu'avec ce type de système
on a la possibilité qui est mobile on a
décidé de produire proche du lieu de
consommation et c'est ça qui est
essentiel pour gérer cette
expérimentation in dépendant klingbeil à
embaucher mourad washi responsable du
prototype
pendant toute cette année est installé
dans un mobile home il veillera 24
heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 sur le
fou de conteneurs j'habite sur la base
indépendant living bays depuis le 3 août
2020 tous les jours je m'occupe de faire
tourner cette base et je m'occupe aussi
tout simplement de faire pousser toutes
ces plantes de suivre leur évolution et
de vérifier leur état de santé et
pour poursuivre jusqu'à la récolte une
vingtaine de variétés de fruits et de
légumes pousseront donc pendant un an
dans cette ferme
insolite une manière de déterminer si le
foot conteneurs autonome pourra devenir
un nouveau système agricole le sport et
je vous le disais dans les titres depuis
le début du confinement une centaine de
sportifs de haut niveau des yvelines
peut continuer à s'entraîner normalement
cette dérogation permet à ces athlètes
de continuer à se préparer physiquement
et techniquement pour les prochaines
échéances le reportage de michael et
demi d'euros
leur quotidien n'a pas été bouleversée
que ce deuxième confinement c'est jeune
tennisman peuvent s'entraîner tous les
jours au comité de tennis des i mean de
fécherolle ils ont obtenu une
autorisation ministérielle pour pouvoir
continuer leurs activités
donc en fait il ya des listes de haut
niveau sportif jeunes au niveau et
je figure dessus en iste l'espoir du
coup j'ai droit de m'entraîner donc je
m'entraîne ici la semaine avec des
partenaires qui sont pareils sur 10 au
niveau et le week end je peux pas aller
dans mon club parce que basses et fermé
c'est vrai que c'est quand même une
chance qu'est-ce qui s'est entraîné
aujourd'hui alors que je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde qui aimeraient être à
ma place ici un fécherolle ils sont une
dizaine à s'entraîner du matin au soir
un vrai plus par rapport au premier
confinement selon les encadrants pendant
le premier confinement du mois de mars
en fait les enfants ont continué à faire
du travail physique chez eux
mais malgré tout ils ont quand même
beaucoup perdu et on a mis du temps à
retrouver un niveau correct donc la
halle avantage c'est que les
entraînements se poursuivent donc il ya
moins de perte s'était l'isma ne sont
pas les seuls à s'entraîner dans les
yvelines ils sont des centaines de
sportifs avoir obtenu cette dérogation
des catégories espoir aux élites on
retrouve notamment des athlètes
susceptibles de partir aux jo de tokyo
l'été prochain comme le versaillais
thomas baroque médaillé de bronze en
aviron en 2016 à rio
si on n'avait pas pu aller dehors
s'entraîner sur l'eau on aurait quand
même pu faire ce qu'on a fait au
printemps dernier
continuer le travail physique dans sa
part exhorté le travail physiologique
mais voilà un sport il n'ya pas que de
la physiologie et aussi beaucoup de
technique de précision et de sensations
et quand il n'est pas sur l'eau mais on
les a pas cette dérogation s'appliquera
jusqu'à la fin du confinement au minimum
jusqu'au 1er décembre
et concernant la pratique amateur on a
d'ailleurs appris aujourd'hui qui
emmanuel macron était favorable à une
reprise du sport dans les clubs pour les
mineurs uniquement et ce dès décembre
un point sera fait le 1er décembre et
une décision sera annoncée en fonction
de l'évolution de la crise sanitaire le
gouvernement travaille sur un protocole
renforcé et sur la mise en place d'un
nouveau masque dit respirant pour faire
du sport
et puis avant de vous laisser cette
information il était à magna le magny
les hameaux le fondateur du comité local
de la fnaca la fédération nationale des
anciens combattants en algérie maroc et
tunisie et jean girard c'était 1 le week
end dernier nous l'avions rencontré à de
nombreuses reprises au fil de reportages
appelé en juillet 1958 il passera 22
mois en algérie il tenait à participer
au travail de mémoire dans les écoles de
la commune et assister à toutes les
cérémonies
il était aussi le fondateur du comité
local du téléthon aujourd'hui l'une des
associations les plus prolifiques dans
les yvelines la commune de magny les
hameaux par la voix de son maire
bertrand ou lyon lui avait fait une
promesse celle de la continuité du lien
et de l'accompagnement des adhérents et
de la transmission de la mémoire pour la
paire en accord avec sa famille des
feuillets sont à disposition en mairie
pour lui rendre hommage
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité
très belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]